ottawa le directeur parlementaire du
budget estime que le déficit du
gouvernement fédéral pourrait atteindre
184 milliards de dollars cette année
selon le scénario étudié ça correspond à
huit et demi pour cent du pib du jamais
vu depuis 1984 la dette atteindrait 8
197 milliards de dollars le directeur
prévoit que le taux de chômage
atteindrait un sommet de 15 % au
troisième trimestre il giroux et le
directeur parlementaire du budget à
ottawa du girou bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
fillion sur quoi vous basez vous le
scénario vous avez présenté aujourd'hui
le scénario présenté aujourd'hui en est
un parmi tant d'autres mais un qu'on
croit possible et ça se base sur des
mesures de confinement qui serait en
place sous une forme ou sous une autre
jusqu'en nous donc pour une période de
six mois et ça se base aussi sur un prix
du pétrole qui serait à son niveau
faible actuel pour une longue période
c'est à dire un scénario où l'arabie
saoudite et la russie ni les pays de
l'opep ne s'entendent pour réduire leur
production ce qui a augmenté les prix du
pétrole donc le prix du pétrole très bas
comme il est présentement fait en sorte
que sa déprime l'économie dans certaines
régions du canada notamment l'alberta et
c'est la base pour ce scénario
économique et financier est ce que vous
êtes en mesure de chiffrer ou de nous
dire quelle part de l'impact budgétaire
vient la cobi 19 et et d'un autre côté à
la chute du pétrole
on a fait ce scénario là un peu sous
pression parce que les choses bougent
très vite donc on ça ne nous a pas
permis de désagréger les deux impacts
étant donné qu'il est dans les deux cas
c'est surtout en cas de lakovic 19
c'est des scénarios qui sont vraiment
inhabituel qu'on n'a pas vu en matière
de modélisation économique puis de
mettre l'économie donc c'est tellement
des scénario inhabituel
quand on l'a on les a intégrés tous les
deux n'ont pas fait la distinction pour
essayer de voir quelle part est
attribuable à la chute des prix du
pétrole bien qu'elle parle est
attribuable uniquement à la cuisse le
deal est clair que la chute des prix du
pétrole est importante dans votre
scénario la faiblesse des cours va
perdurer toute l'année selon votre
estimation
c'est le scénario qu'on a un visa
j'en ai fait avec un prix du pétrole qui
reste bois tout au cours de l'année 2020
et qui ne se remet pas à la route dans
un horizon de court terme
peut-être un moyen terme ça va toujours
dépend de comment les choses évoluent
sur le marché mondial du pétrole
mais pour l'instant on n'entrevoit pas
de hausse du prix du pétrole d'ici la
fin 2020 pour le chômage vous avez un
scénario à 15% au troisième trimestre on
va le voir au troisième trimestre 12 % à
la fin de l'année les économistes vont
pas jusqu'à 15% dans les prévisions
pourquoi vous allez à ce niveau là dans
votre scénario
dans notre scénario on estimé que les
chiffres du marché du travail qui ont
été divulgués ce matin montre là à peu
près un million de pertes d'emplois puis
ce scénario là le scénario économique on
l'a on l'a émis le 27 mars et les
chiffres qui sont sortis ce matin ont
démontré une perte d'emploi d'un million
11000 donc c'est la base sur laquelle on
sait on a on en a ri mais notre scénario
économique et c'est là dessus qu'on
s'est basé pour faire nos prévisions de
taux de chômage
jusqu'à maintenant malheureusement les
faits nous donnent raison et c'est la
base pour pour estimer le taux de
chômage pour les trimestre 2,3 icap de
l'année pour ça monsieur giroud c'est
clair que ce serait un record depuis que
les chiffres sont colligées par
statistique canada de cette façon là en
1976 malheureusement record qu'on veut
pas répéter qu'on espère un honnêtement
se tromper la team
on croit malheureusement pas et donc
vous avez un graphique également dans
votre étude de ce matin sur le potentiel
de reprise du pib potentiel et du pib
réel on vraiment une chute importante là
au deuxième trimestre parce que ça va
jusqu'à 25% de recul mais décrivez la
suite là est-ce que ça s'appelle une
reprise en u en l on peut l'appeler à l
on l'appelle peut-être un peu plus
familièrement en bâton d'or qui parce
que il ya une chute assez abrupte qui
est suivie par une reprise assez graduel
de l'économie mais on s'attend
clairement parce que ce soit une reprise
envie ça
une chute abrupte de l'activité
économique qui suivit par un rebond de
même ampleur
on voit vraiment pas ça c'est pas dans
la nature de l'économie canadienne de
subi des chutes forte suivi de rebond
assez prononcé on s'attend vraiment à
une reprise graduelle et progressive
une fois que lee le pire de la coved
veille de passer donc vous le scénario
sur lequel vous travaillez qui sommes le
plus possible plausible c'est pas un
scénario extrêmement optimiste on peut
dire comme ça malheureusement non à
cause des deux facteurs qu'on connaît
bien les prix du pétrole et la coved 19
et aussi en raison des caractéristiques
de l'économie canadienne
une économie répartis géographiquement
assez bien diversifié donc quand il ya
un choc brutal l'économie ont pas
tendance à reprendre avec un fort rebond
où il ya pas d impulsion très très
dynamique qui fait ressortir qui fait
rebondir l'économie canadienne et c'est
ce qu'on a expérimenté malheureusement
lors la crise financière de 2008 2009
une chute assez précipité de l'activité
économique et une reprise très graduelle
crie on s'attend ce que ce soit encore
la même chose
donc ça veut dire quoi sur les finances
publiques en 2021 22 pour la suite des
choses
on sait pas hasardé à faire un scénario
à faire des prévisions étant donné que
même qu'on essaie de prévoir qu est ce
qui va se passer dans l'année financière
actuelle c'est très difficile avec les
annonces qui se bousculent
jour après jour mais c'est clair qu'on
viendra pas à l' équilibre financier de
l'année prochaine probablement pas là
n'est clairement pas l'année suivante
non plus à moins d'un miracle donc ça
augure d'une lente reprise de l'économie
mais aussi une amélioration graduelle du
solde budgétaire du gouvernement fédéral
est aussi probablement des gouvernements
provinciaux donc une amélioration
graduelle mais pas de rebond ni du côté
des finances publiques ni du côté de
l'économie
merci beaucoup et le giro merci ça me
fait plaisir aux rats